reprend le centre jeunesse arrive
[Musique]
ça valait chéri tout va bien merci et
franck broca le réalisateur de
l'émission mon franck comment tu sens
les missions sont alors eh bien
justement les chéris ce soir on savait
qu'on reçoit patrick sébastien mignotte
et pour démarrer
je vais demander au 1er patrick
sébastien mais ce qu'on va faire à qui
sera le meilleur patrick sébastien le
1er patrick sébastien de rentrer sur
scène
[Applaudissements]
but as you go go
[ __ ] si longtemps de cela je suis
content d'être là le fidèle ami cours
mettez le dans l'air ok je suis
tellement content de naissance qui tombe
ok ok ça
le combattant
question de ferrer
ouattara vainqueur ces arrêts
prêtant s'améliore celle que nous venons
enfin allez on fait tourner smina
gigabit ou le carnaval que je suis bien
à la logique et
[Musique]
oh
les bestiaux
au revoir les esprits
non
[Musique]
je savais toujours faire
star
on va lancer le ballon
très
quant au fils à jo h au sommet de la
fiesta
tél
moto que junior par les jeunes
quant au petit lancy suis là c'est pas
la tuer et à soi
c'est pousser un coup de gueule quand on
se reconnaît alain bauer a plus tard
donné bien ici papa tu sais qu'on tienne
compte m watch faire un petit cadeau tu
te sortir mon plus gros tubes table y
compris la blague du groupe humain à la
musique à ses parents
les sarries d'avoir bien
à tort
bon bien être dans ces deux là vont se
rassembler et on sait tous qu'on
n'entendra du thé reprendre
changer ça
chanter ça arrive
chante les arrivants villé
obama
au programme une chanteuse arrive à
gérer pour le set
[Musique]